les années casber tôt
dès la fin des années 1950
l'organisation urbaine de saint denis
mais plus généralement celle des
principales villes de la réunion connaît
de profonds bouleversements
les deux décennies suivantes son capital
pour l'histoire de l'architecturé
unionaises il est nécessaire de
construire toujours plus de maisons et
d'immeubles pour loger une population
dont le nombre s'accroît
considérablement au cours des années 60
les lotissements résidentiels se
multiplient au coeur des villes et sur
les terrains voués autrefois
l'agriculture c'est là qu'apparaît une
nouvelle architecture adaptée à la
petite et moyenne bourgeoisie la case
béton les gros cabinets d'architectes
réalise des plans types donnant ainsi à
toutes ces constructions un air de
famille parmi les grandes nouveautés
l'utilisation d'un matériau phare le
parpaing et bien sûr la multiplication
des maisons à étage et des toitures
terrasses remplaçant les toits à quatre
pentes le modèle le plus répondu et
dessiné par l'architecte guy lejeune
fidèle à la tradition réunionnaise ces
maisons disposent d'une varangue ici si
tu en angle il est doté également d'un
garage annexes qui se généralise dans
l'habitat durant cette période il perce
leur face à de nombreuses fenêtres afin
de faciliter la ventilation naturelle
des pièces
typique de l'architecturé de la seconde
moitié du 20e siècle
ces cases béton aux formes très moderne
représente aujourd'hui plus de 80% du
patrimoine architectural réunionnais